well control of Congress is at stake in
the midterm elections less than two
weeks from now and both parties are
courting women voters in close races
across the country we visited Morris
County New Jersey in the state's 11th
congressional district in 2016 voters
there elected a Republican to Congress
by a margin of about 20 points but
president Trump carried the district by
only four points Democrats hope to turn
it blue this November we spoke with four
college-educated suburban women there
Barbara and Natalie are Republicans
while Cheryl and Jessica are Democrats
and while the women differ on politics
they all agree that there's too much on
the line to sit this election out what
is the number one issue for you going
into this midterm election check on the
presidency and return to civility in
addition to health care I would say I'm
more concerned with results and I
actually think the country needs to be
less politically correct checks and
balances it's out of control
any elected official or candidate
running for office also just their
stances on local government because
politics is local and we tend to forget
that is this country better off two
years after this presidents been elected
I'm from the economy standpoint under
the Trump administration the stock
market for example has continued to grow
if you will I would say yes he has been
good for the economy he's removed a lot
of restrictions on business I'm pleased
with tax reform that he has made this is
the lowest unemployment rate that we're
enjoying if the economy is doing so well
why do you think that there is so much
passion going into this midterm from
both sides I think people don't like
Trump and that's been evident from the
moment he took office and it's just
built up to a fever pitch the press
coverage of Trump is overwhelmingly
negative it's really his own press
coverage though like you follow him on
Twitter he tweets these ridiculous
things I am a minority and honestly I I
am NOT a fond of his language but he's
he's what the country is needed I mean
that's the way I see with the way the
economy
see I would if I made just one less
quick thing frankly a lot of people feel
that you know at what cost
is that what for how long can this
really I sustained and sometimes people
are making trade-offs and if we have
people have money in their pockets but
yet there are fights and and riots in
the streets at some point that's even
going to impact our do you want to be on
our leaders from both parties in
Congress doing enough to bring back
civility I would say both parties are
not doing enough but right now and I do
think the Democrats are more culpable I
just feel like the Republicans are and
I've never been such a party line person
but I feel like the Republicans are just
selling their souls we need more people
like Senator flake that did end up
bringing some unity to the country at a
time that it just desperately needed it
we're guilty on both sides as mothers is
the country moving in the right
direction in terms of your children's
futures no no I'm very concerned about
their safety and I think that the
Republican Party is really committed to
helping you know the upper echelon of
income and to the expense and detriment
of people from less advantaged
communities I think when Obama left
office something like 20% of the
population felt this country was moving
in the right direction that number is
now in the 40s so a majority of people
and I'm among them do think that the
country is starting to turn itself
around yeah I'm worried for my
children's future I don't think the
country is going in the right direction
at all they sent some pain when you were
talking about your children I don't know
if there's more of a story there that
you're concerned about well my daughter
had two incidents went during the
election where she was called the n-word
twice and that never happened we lived
in I don't want to get like emotional
it's very real though
yeah your husband is Puerto Rican yeah
none of my kids have ever had any issues
and then twice in the same year so wait
and you can't tell me it's not because
of Trump you can't tell me we've spent
all this time talking about President
Trump so is
this election as he would like to say a
referendum on him hmm arguably it is
mm-hmm it is somewhat yeah I think so
it's really precarious for Democrats and
Republicans alike every the the fight is
on I don't know how any other way to put
it such an impressive group of women and
we spent over an hour talking I would
say it's 15 minutes of that was about
Kavanagh and the Cavanaugh effect and
the Republicans women saying that that
they over pulled the Democrats
overplayed their hand and that's why
you're gonna see a Republican resurgence
at the polls and Democrats continued to
talk about what effect and impact that
had on Democratic women and why you'll
see them come out to the pool why did
you choose that district that district
is in a heated election right now we
have a can't the current congressman
there is retiring that typically that
district it would leaned Republican now
it could be leaning Democrat so that's
gonna be a tight race to watch we're
gonna be covering them two weeks they
all had a lot to say they very good very
good conversation yeah